I look awesome guys I've deface the
picture with my crowbar so you can't see
the tips anymore so everything's fine
wait wait no how dare you
where's the tits I heard about kids show
me tits all right tits don't disappear
what are you talking about is that it
come on I'll give her the other one
let's fix it phase two hello Danka Danka
that's hot someone hit me I'm just
making sure I just making sure he wasn't
the trainer wait so I think we need I
think we need to find some clues here
yeah we can't just jump to conclusions I
am stuck in this room oh wait am i okay
I'm free what's happening I'm miss
clicking what happened miss khatola he's
shooting me he's shooting me oh it's
minx isn't it
oh no it's minx oh no minx what are you
doing what are you doing oh my god now
what are you talking about what are you
talking about you crazy yeah what are
you guys putting those guns huh
who shot brutally brutally it's Bromley
I saw him oh yeah I shot a shotgun see I
saw him do that my feelings are hurt a
lot okay see I think it's Felix again he
looks very very much how do you you
can't see my face how can you tell
don't lie to me and not see I can see
your face right hey hey we're all we're
all twins here okay we should all be
together we should be wait what are
forward twins called Quinn apples quad
cry quad quadlings
we're quadlings we're quadlings we
should just go out and have fun and
enjoy life instead of accusing each
other we spend too much time in life
just doing that already
so you're still okay with his being shot
no no
my rescue oh boy you said it we have I
think we have a traitor over here what
is that oh but the game isn't over Ken
why did you die you saw me are you
talking about I'm looking for a gun so I
can kill I mean so we can party about be
nice to each other oh I just want I just
want there's knives everywhere I can
would you use them damn it
and banana you guys took all the cool
guns I think it's either Ming sir oh
sure he shot me right the banana side
shoot him shoot him shoot him shoot him
shoot him
why just no one stop him
whoa whoa whoa what what is this just
wanted to see if your leg was traitorous
come on come on so your leg is fine body
you're like how are you even running how
are you even running right now - clearly
it banks how the trick is how do
something okay well we're just poking
it's Facebook just poking just poking
hey I just want you it's one of you want
to use the traitor no we're just poking
died from your post
okay okay yeah kid is way too quiet
I don't know mix mix come on I don't
like this this attitude of yours okay I
think you're too - I think you want them
to add too much what's added PTT c4
somewhat seaboard
was it who was it
that's a good C for that alright let's
create some fire a finite fanfiction
okay sit in my lap Santa can stop
sniping them okay it's probably minx
because when minx gets really aggressive
yeah that's true that's true
cálmate let's Joe thanks Meg's Newton I
have no crystal battle against Meeks
it's me how do we I'm trying to get I
don't know how I get up on the building
so let's go back where you go god damn
it no
[Laughter]
help help Meg so kill me I need your
help yes we do we have to give thanks to
you what that note no the railing fell
off that's not fair praise the YT
watermelon I was I was gonna teleport
don't kill the watermelon you didn't do
anything this is maddening words matter
yeah I'm gonna try to be more careful
this time around I was pretty careful
until the floor collapsed beneath me
okay oh god damn it
are you [ __ ] I didn't know it's
starting I wasn't see the thing about
that one was you weren't even trying to
cross something usually straight up
you didn't see it what's that what's the
prayer we have to say to the watermelon
Jesus o great watermelon Jesus wait can
I become the watermelon yes I am I'll
add it in your face
guys no Ivan died as a watermelon god
dammit I'm still falling in there I died
for like an artsy film or something did
I land on your face can ya did you like
it I'm gonna slap you with my banana
bananas together yeah sounds like a
German porn uh alright now it became
Japanese they're really weird [ __ ]
everybody weeks okay okay that's all
let's all trust each other why do you
want us to go there huh why did you
polish it and the d-day what's up
[ __ ] but this guy means the beacon
[Music]
it's not that bad hey can I see you
nighty just one minute just one minute I
think I think I left it at home
are you are you the bouncer in this club
sir hey yeah I'm the Bansi hey Birds I
got an ID I'm quiet
I don't like hey hey hey hey hey hey get
me you don't get to what
what were you trying to say please tell
me what she was and this is actually a
very unpleasant place to be stuck
forever killing me man hello you try to
squeeze thank you no I was internally
shot okay I don't like giving mixi I
want a gun I'm gonna go up there
where's my gun minx he promised me again
where's again wait I have a gun oh you
just throw that did you just throw that
she threw her name oh god no
he watched me burn me can look at okay
I'm gonna replay how many times I said
it was Ken yeah it's totally Ken it's
Ken I know a kid's voice by now and he's
using his canvas okay whoa hey guys wait
in front of the the hey come back come
back bridge come back come back
Britt how do you I don't even know how
you like do that okay come up look at me
you I love you can thank you
[Laughter]
that is the best TTT victory ever
[Music]
you